en represión terminaron las
manifestaciones contra la reforma a la
Justicia del Primer Ministro quien
respaldó que la policía utilizara gases
lacrimógenos contra los que protestaban
no podemos aceptar la violencia no
podemos aceptar la violencia contra la
policía no podemos aceptar el bloqueo de
carreteras no podemos aceptar atacar a
figuras públicas y sus familias algo que
está sucediendo ahora entre la vidrio
y lo digo de nuevo frente a los
infractores que cruzaron una línea roja
hoy ante la VIP no toleraremos una
situación en la que una persona haga lo
que cree que es justo
en las calles la gente respondió a la
intervención del Primer Ministro
[Música]
puedes ver que está mintiendo deseo que
algo cambie aquí
[Música]
la reforma judicial que pretende
implementar el gobierno Ultra
conservador de metanyahu le daría una
influencia en elección de jueces
limitaría el alcance de las decisiones
de la Corte Suprema y permitiría al acné
set o parlamento no reconocerlas con
solo una mayoría simple las encuestas
muestran que las reformas impopular
entre los ciudadanos ya que para ellos
podrían verse afectadas las libertades
individuales por lo que las protestas ya
cumplen semanas el presidente de Israel
una figura sin muchas funciones en el
país quiere que la salida sea negociada
no permitiré que nuestro estado de
Israel de todos nosotros llegue al punto
de no retorno no permitiré que ocurra
este desastre histórico nunca renunciaré
a ninguna parte de la sociedad israelí
ni a la oportunidad de alcanzar un
amplio consenso
la reforma aún no se ha convertido en
ley y siguen discusiones en el acné set
de mayoría oficialista Pero ha generado
preocupación internacional por el estado
de la democracia israelí